vivimos momentos que son extremadamente
graves porque rusia decidió
aumentar su ofensiva y las próximas
horas los próximos días estarán marcados
por una ofensiva cada vez más masiva en
el donbass y también mariupol con los
dramas humanos como los que hemos podido
constatar en varias ciudades ya el rol
de francia y el rol de europa es como
nosotros lo hicimos desde el principio
primero que todo mandó apoyar a ucrania
para que resiste apoyar y ayudando a los
ucranianos con equipos de defensa y
también para el combate y para que no
caiga a kiev
también apoyarlos económicamente que
también están también algo que hemos
hecho apoyar al pueblo
ucrania no recibiendo a más de 5
millones de personas que ya han salido
para irse a europa y eso va a cambiar
por supuesto la vida europa hay que ir
más lejos
creo que hoy hay que intensificar y
mantener esta línea con mucha fuerza
como lo hemos hecho
haciendo como yo he tratado de hacer de
lograr que esta guerra no escale y que
no se salga de esas fronteras entonces
tenemos que reforzar también
lo que hemos establecido con francia y
los aliados y también mantener los otros
países también por eso he discutido con
china con india con los países del golfo
para que puedan tomar conciencia de que
rusia optó por una vía que es funesta
para
ella misma y para el equilibrio de las
naciones y por eso europa es tan
importante una europa fuerte de peso
con una defensa fuerte como la de
francia y por eso invertí en nuestra
armada para tener para hacer los 50.000
millones
según la ley de programación militar y
hacer que francia sea una fuerza de
equilibrio que permita mantener nuestra
seguridad en la larga duración y evitar
que se expanda este conflicto porque no
somos vasallos de nadie y
llevar a rusia para razón para unos es
el fuego y después liberar el territorio
ucraniano